hello my name is Joelle angevine and
today I am going to take you through my
journey of becoming Google cloud
certified I'll give you an introduction
to who I am a bit about my certification
journey the impact it has had in my
career and then leave you with some
takeaways so let's get started with an
introduction my name is Joelle and I'm a
solution engineer at Google cloud I am
currently a Google cloud certified
professional data engineer associate
cloud engineer and professional cloud
architect I'm really really happy to be
here today to share my story with you
it's interesting to think of my journey
as a three by three by three three
countries three states and three
certifications I was born in Guyana in
South America I grew up in the Bahamas
and in the USA I have lived in Texas and
New York City before eventually moving
to California for my current role I have
always been an inquisitive person since
birth for example in Diana my father
used to buy mint candies before church
every week and I used to divvy them up
amongst my family to make sure that we
all had the same amount
over the years that natural instinct for
data and analysis has led me to grow
into a thoughtful and analytical
technology professional and I'm really
grateful to be in a role here at Google
that allows me to own an on and grow
those skills now let's look at my
certification story
I have bucketed today story into three
major milestones in my journey they are
moving to New York City growing my
network and deciding to move forward to
become certified I have been a user of
Google cloud tools for about three and a
half years now and I have been working
in the cloud space for about that long
as well my experience really started
when I first moved to New York City I
moved there for a marketing engineering
program
advertising technology space and after
that program ended I got a job as a
platform analyst at a small start-up and
I'm really grateful for that role that's
actually where I started to get my hands
on GCP experience my first step into
Google Cloud was with bigquery in the
client interface and about a month and a
half after I joined the team our company
was actually acquired by another company
and that is where I was introduced to
how to work in multi cloud environments
since the company that acquired us was
actually working with another cloud
service provider at that time so I
learned how to integrate and how to
migrate data across cloud services and
as I continued to grow in my career I
eventually became a consultant when I
was introduced to the world of cloud
architecture and how to use various
Google cloud tools to build a full
solution then document that solution
with technical documentation all of this
was really valuable to me and it all
started with my move to New York City I
not only got hands on Google cloud
experience but I got brown cloud
experience as well
the takeaway that I want to note here is
don't be afraid to change have the
confidence to take the first step now
moving on to my network I highly highly
recommend that you seek out and nurture
healthy opportunities to build your
network this is what really helped me
expand my confidence as a technology
professional I grueling network through
meetups industry events and
organizations such as the Houston Google
developers group which partnered with
women techmakers for some of the events
I attended and meetups in New York
cities such as the tackiest diversity
and tech meetup along with the Houston
GCP user group check out your local tech
community to see what's available to you
if there aren't any or many options I
encourage you to create one now I just
shared with you that I did have quite a
bit of hands-on experience on the Google
cloud platform however what I
come to realize over the past year or so
it's that I was moreso thinking of
myself as someone who knew how to use a
tool rather than someone who was a
professional in the cloud industry and
when my thinking really turned around
was during the Google cloud learning
workshop which is one of Google's
diversity equity and inclusion
initiatives to bring more perspectives
into the cloud industry one of my
favorite parts of the workshop was
meeting with other professionals with
varying years of experience and varying
levels of expertise in the cloud space
this really helped to broaden my
horizons and deepen my understanding of
the use of GCP across use cases I
realized as some of the professionals in
the room have been working on technical
infrastructure concepts before the
concept of cloud computing was even
widely known and I also realized that
there were professionals in the room
like myself who were learning about
technical infrastructure concepts
through cloud computing rather than the
other way around and what I noticed in
conversations with my cohort is that I
was actually able to share knowledge and
ideas as if I had been working in this
industry for five or ten years and my
confidence grew dramatically as I
realized that I really didn't know what
I was talking about as a result of my
hands-on experience in this new industry
when you get that boost of confidence
you continue to grow it and that's
exactly what I did this isn't really was
a great turning point for me as I
continue to grow as a leader at a
technology professional since being able
to speak clearly and with confidence is
an important trait of being in a
leadership role my takeaway for you here
is to identify your goals and surround
yourself with others who have achieved
something similar or who have achieved
something bigger than themselves and
begin to network with them you might be
amazed at how that can transform your
mindset as well so now with all of that
being said I'm done as I continue to
grow in my confidence I was also
introduced
the world of certification itself
previously I had seen certification as
something that someone with many more
years of experience and I had with go
for and maybe I could go for it in a few
years as well
however after my experience in the
learning workshop I began to realize
that certification could be the right
route for me and I also saw it as a
great achievement to really solidify my
egg cloud expertise and when it comes to
the action of taking the exam this is a
wonderful story that I'm proud of as
well
I took the Associated cloud engineer
exam in August and did not pass it
honestly was so disappointing because I
was looking forward to passing it as
many of us do when we take exams so I
did take some time to these be
disappointed and then I decided to move
on I took a look at the areas in the
exam that I felt the most uncomfortable
with and then I also explored exam
topics in general across across the
Google cloud certifications and
throughout that review period after
reevaluating my skills I realized that
the data engineering certification was
potentially the right route for me
especially since I was coming from the
world of data and I had hands-on
experience with cloud technologies in
the data space so I took the data
engineering exam and passed I was so
excited it was actually three weeks
after I had failed the associate cloud
engineer exam and I was happy and proud
of myself
fast forward to February of this year
when after months of study and months of
additional practice across the Google
cloud platform tools I was able to pass
both the professional cloud architect
exam and the associate cloud engineer
exam on the same day my takeaway for you
here is to stay focused and know how you
learn best and let that lead how you
study for the certification exams
if certification is one of your goals
becoming Google cloud certified had an
important impact on my career this
impact
included immediate career benefits
long-term professional gains and new
opportunities for mentorship in terms of
immediate career benefits and the role
that I was in at the time becoming
certified open doors for me to attend a
really cool industry conference on
behalf of my employer at that time I
felt like it was a really cool reward
and a great opportunity for me and it
also provided me with more of a voice in
the project engagement that I was in at
that time now on to long term
professional games a big one has been
the opportunity to work at Google this
has been a dream of mine and a goal of
mine for a while at Google I am a
solution engineer on a team called the
cloud solution studio and what we do is
really really cool I along with my team
build assets for our sales teams which
demonstrate Google cloud solutions
across use cases in my role I have the
opportunity to build on my Google cloud
certifications and knowledge to use
storytelling design thinking and project
management skills to bring our solutions
to life I have been at Google for over
six months now and it's been really
great I got involved in the black
Googler Network where I have a great
buddy who has given me advice and has
also just been a great friend including
giving me recommendations or
hairdressers which has been really
useful since I'm new to the Bay Area I
have also been pretty active in Google's
outreach efforts including our grow with
Google initiative giving back to the
cloud Google cloud learning workshop and
other certification outreach efforts and
last but not least getting certified has
opened doors to mentorship as part of
the learning workshop I met someone who
is actually still one of my mentors to
this day I reached out to her and we
stayed in contact
Inaba I'm here at Google I'm able to
meet with her on a regular basis and
talk about how I am growing as a
professional I really do value her
five and her input into the growth areas
that we discuss now before we wrap up I
do want to share some takeaways that I
think would be valuable for you no
matter where you are on your journey and
where you are in your certification path
as well the first is to look at the
growth goals that you have set for
yourself and have the confidence to take
the first step it can always feel
daunting to do this in my case it was
daunting to look at others who were
certified and think well I can be
certified to yet it required me to take
the first step for me that looked like
being part of the learning workshop
taking courses and studying diligently
and even taking the first step of
registering to take the exams I
encourage you to also have the
confidence to take the first step and
believe in yourself I would also
recommend that you proactively build
your network seek out opportunities to
learn from partner with and help those
who have achieved things similar to the
goals you have set for yourself also
consider seeking out guidance from those
who have achieved things bigger than
themselves this will help you to better
understand what it takes to get where
you need to be and it will help with
accountability along your attorney it
can be really easy to make goals and
then not follow up if you have put
certification as a professional or even
personal goal for yourself then go for
it proactively build your network and
make sure that you have a level of
accountability and consider giving back
by being a mentor to someone else
especially after you're certified last
but not least discover your unique
approach this can take on numerous
meanings in the certification space I
would say to discover the way you learn
best and craft your study plan around
that as an example from my end I
realized that I learn best by testing
myself getting hands-on experience and
being able to tie backs
variance to the concepts so knowing this
I crafted my personal study plans around
those principles I recommend that you
take a look at your experiences as a
learner and see the ways that you have
learned best then take that and create a
personal study plan for yourself make
sure you're being true to yourself thank
you so much for your time I really
appreciate the opportunity to share my
story with you and hopefully being able
to inspire you to craft a story of your
own that you can be proud of be sure to
check out the appendix of this deck for
additional certification resources have
a great day and perhaps I will see you
soon